Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is
Not Allowed To Do At The Foundation:
No ending reports with lyrics from
"The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air".
Sometimes work at the SCP Foundation can get a
bit grueling, so Dr. Bright tries to “brighten”
everyone’s day with a little pop culture
reference or two. However, after a report
on SCP-096’s potential origins concluded with
“In West of the Arctic, born and raised, in the
mountains is where he spent most of his days.”
His colleagues agreed that enough was enough.
However, after he submitted a formal
request, he was given certain allowances.
Mainly, he can use lyrics from Safety Dance,
as the majority of the research staff still
find them funny. Most notably, he ended a report
on SCP-049 with: “You can cure if you want to,
you can leave your friends behind. Cause
your friends got plague and if they’ve
got plague then they’re no friends of mine!”
After his accompanying dance nearly broke a window
and triggered a containment breach of SCP-173,
however, his boogying privileges were revoked.